six people have resigned from Donald
Trump's special hiv-aids advisory
council because they say Trump does just
doesn't care about it on Saturday six of
the 21 Council members wrote resignation
letters which were published in Newsweek
and the letter said quote as advocates
for people living with HIV we have
dedicated our lives to combating this
disease and no longer feel we can do so
effectively within the confines of an
advisory body to a president who simply
does not care the Trump administration
has no strategy to address the ongoing
hiv/aids epidemic seeks zero input from
experts to formulate HIV policy and most
concerning Lee pushes legislation that
will harm people living with HIV and
halt or reverse important gains made in
the fight against this disease wait a
second Trump refusing to take advice
from experts that's so hard for me to
believe right this is a White House
committee which was established 22 years
ago under President Bill Clinton it
consists of top medical experts public
health officials people living with HIV
and AIDS those don't sound like people
Donald Trump takes advice from if only
they had Fox News shows or some
predatory business then maybe Trump
would be listening to them all of a
sudden but again the problem seems to be
Trump just doesn't care Trump doesn't
care about this stuff I mean I know when
you're president there's so many
departments and fields that you have to
do to focus your interest on yeah but
you know it would help your case if you
weren't watching six hours of television
every day and that if you had a staff to
delegate responsibility and plan playing
more than a round of golf every single
week
Lucy Bradley Springer is a member of the
Council one of the six members who quit
and she teaches at the University of
Denver Medical School and is a
specialist in infectious diseases and
she said about this quote after the
inauguration and after I saw how this
administration is going after so many
things that make a difference in HIV I
just felt like I can't be on that
council and say I was working for the
current administration something else
that's interesting just compare the
website of Donald Trump's HIV AIDS
Council with that of President
rock obama here's the website and this
is a visual thing this was the website
of the Office of National AIDS policy
under Barack Obama videos of President
Obama actually talking about the issue
they had a blog staff biographies
mission statement actual material right
here is Donald Trump's version of the
Office of National AIDS policy basically
the entire website has been removed and
apparently it wasn't important enough to
put together a new even basic website
people are embarrassed to work for
Donald Trump this can't be the only
government office where morale has been
affected by Donald Trump we've talked
about the Park Service we've talked
about so many of these this is a
presidency that in its five months and
two days so far has been a disaster not
only directly but there's probably some
larger domino effect where government
workers are feeling beaten and
disillusioned because their jobs are
being made both more difficult and also
sort of written off is not important
implicitly by this administration well I
just think that because HIV and AIDS was
more of a prevalent issue back in the
80s people think that it's entirely
solved but that's not the case when you
have over a million people that are HIV
positive in the country and and there's
a lot of clueless people um if you look
at some of the articles about this
there's right-wingers in the comments
online saying oh but but these these
scientists are the problem because if
they really care about AIDS why would
they quit they don't care about hiv/aids
because they quit their posts they're
quitting to maybe go work on this issue
elsewhere aren't they like I think it's
really weird to say it's the scientists
who don't care because they're quitting
yeah their work would be better done
somewhere else I guess outside of the
administration very very strange
criticism